ベーコンとかいっぱい
いろんなお
大きいベーコンが乗ってたって言ったっけ
誰からそういう話
ベーコンが乗ってるからって
美味しそうだと思って
こんな大きなベーコンなの
ただにしてた
日本ってさベーコンじゃなくてハムなんだよ
そうよね
ハムは
美味しい
だから
電話かけても
普段は誰も出ないわけ
みんなそこで働いてる人が
3人か4人同じ電話を
向かってるらしいのよ
よく知らないんだけど
いくらかけても誰も出たことがないってね
それで帰ったわけ
それで大失敗した
行ってくれればいいのにって感じ
なんか返事してくれるわね
いつもわかったんだけど
それで
なんでだろう
それでなんかあの
それで今度ずっとほっといてね
もう行かないでな
なんかある時あの
なんかちょっともう仕事終わったって
いつもあの
夜は夜は夜は遅くまで働いてたのね
ああ
だからもうお家帰るのってちょっと帰ってある時から
今雨来ててね
そのカバスとそれと両方もお隣をって
帰ってきられちゃった
ああ
もういつもなんで
私も本当にこんなおばあちゃんと
散らしてる
いやいやいや
いや
まだまだ
みんな笑ってるんじゃない
ああ
いやいや
そうなっちゃったんだ
でもなんかその
ポテト行った時
あの誰がいたんだ
誰か
そのなんて
お客さんじゃないか
誰か連れてったのよ
他の知ってる
他の女性の方を
誰だったっけ
あれを
連れてたんだけど
なんか4人ぐらいで行ってね
私と言って
へえ
それでその時ね
そのお客さんに来たら
他の自動車の
整理してる人
他にみんな連れて挨拶になってきたの
ああ
そういう
あ
でもそうか
そのカップ前だって
ああ
そうか
だから
英語の方が来てくれたら
思うな
って言って
へえ
はい
私は
いろんなところで
持てるんです
笑